so this is a relatively inexpensive
multi-touch surface which I made here at
cinema the helpless my boss Adrian tweed
and it's a pretty simple setup we have
these two lasers with a refracted line
and see the line goes all the way across
across the wall and all that reflects it
is these little acrylic rods which i
mounted which i taped onto the front of
the laser and this little webcam that we
got and it's hooked to a computer with a
computer vision package running max/msp
jitter and it's not a true multi-touch
but it's a pretty good approximation so
if you watch this little visualization
you can see my finger kind of running
across the surface I can do two fingers
just as easily and three fingers or
fingers and hooked it up to a simple
little musical instrument which gives
you these kind of theremin like gritty
sci-fi sounds
so you can see that x coordinate is
pitch and why is amplitude you can do
two fingers
what else is cool about this system is
that the laser makes a line across your
finger and you can actually measure the
aspect ratio of that line and as you
bend your finger back and forth the
aspect ratio changes a little so and
that's shown in this little bar here you
can see that it changes slightly as I
kind of then my finger back and forth
and the pitch also changes since I'm
moving the little so that's this system
relatively inexpensive multi-touch
instrument made here at sin that